Combien de Créationnistes y a-t-il parmi nous?
Sans doute aucun ; je pense que nous sommes tous Darwiniens.
Et pourtant, beaucoup d'évolutionnistes sont nerveux, mal à l'aise,
et voudraient savoir jusqu'où va exactement l'évolutionnisme.
Bien.
Les toiles d'araignées? Bien sûr, elles sont le produit de l'évolution.
La Toile de l'Internet? Pas sûr.
Un barrage de castor, oui. Le barrage de Hoover, non.
Ils pensent : Qu'est ce qui empêche les résultats de l'ingéniosité humaine
d'être eux-mêmes des fruits de l'arbre de la vie,
et ainsi, d'une certaine façon, d'obéir aux règles de l'évolution?
Et pourtant, de façon intéressante les gens sont réticents
à l'idée d'appliquer la pensée de l'évolution à la pensée, à notre pensée.
Donc je vais vous parler un petit peu de ça,
en me rappelant que le programme est bien chargé.
Donc, vous vous promenez dans les bois, ou dans un pré,
et vous voyez cette fourmi escaladant un brin d'herbe.
Elle monte en haut, et elle tombe,
et elle monte, et elle tombe, et elle monte...
En essayant de rester à l'extrémité du brin d'herbe.
Que fait cette fourmi? A quoi ca lui sert?
Quels buts essaye-t-elle d'atteindre en escaladant ce brin d'herbe?
Qu'est ce qu'elle a à y gagner?
La réponse est : Rien. La fourmi n'a rien à y gagner.
Bon, alors, pourquoi fait-elle ça?
Est-ce juste par hasard?
Oui, c'est par hasard, c'est un parasite. Une douve du foie.
C'est un petit ver dans le cerveau.
C'est un ver parasite du cerveau qui doit aller dans l'estomac d'un mouton ou d'un vache
pour continuer son cycle de vie.
Les saumons remontent les rivières jusqu'à leur lieu de frai,
et la douve du foie réquisitionne une fourmi,
rampe jusqu'à son cerveau, et la conduit en haut d'un brin d'herbe comme un 4x4.
Donc la fourmi n'a rien à y gagner.
Le cerveau de la fourmi a été piraté par un parasite qui infecte le cerveau,
entraînant un comportement suicidaire.
Plutôt effrayant.
Bon, est ce que quelque chose comme ca peut arriver à un être humain?
En mettant à part les problème génétiques, bien sur.
Et bien, vous avez peut-être déjà pensé
que "Islam" signifiait "se rendre" ou "soumettre ses intérêts propre à la volonté d'Allah".
Ce sont les idées, pas les vers, qui piratent nos cerveaux.
Bon, suis-je en train de dire qu'une minorité non négligeable de la population mondiale
a eu son cerveau piraté par une idée parasite?
Non, c'est pire que ca.
La plupart des gens le sont.
(Rires)
On peut mourir pour beaucoup d'idées.
La Liberté, si vous êtes du New Hampshire.
(Rires)
La Justice, la Vérité, le Communisme.
Beaucoup de gens ont donné leur vie pour le communisme.
et beaucoup l'ont donnée pour le capitalisme.
Et beaucoup pour le Catholicisme. Et beaucoup pour l'Islam.
C'est juste quelques unes des idées pour lesquelles on peut mourir.
Elles sont contagieuses.
Hier, Amory Lovins a parlé de "répétitions infectieuses"
En fait, c'était dépréciateur.
C'est de l'ingénierie qui ne pense pas.
En fait, la plus grande partie de l'expansion culturelle en cours
n'est pas géniale, nouvelle, avec de nouveaux points de vue.
Ce sont des répétitions infectieuses.
Et on pourrait essayer de construire une théorie de ce qui se passe quand cela arrive,
de façon à comprendre les conditions de l'infection.
Les hôtes travaillent dur pour répandre ces idées.
Personnellement, je suis un philosophe, et l'un des risques du métier
est la question que nous pose les gens sur le sens de la vie.
Et vous devez avoir un slogan,
vous savez, une phrase toute faite.
Voici la mienne
Le secret du bonheur est : Trouvez quelque chose de plus important que vous
et dédiez y votre vie.
La plupart d'entre nous, maintenant que la "génération égoïste" est bien passée,
c'est ce que nous faisons.
Un jeu d'idées ou un autre
a tout simplement remplacer les impératifs biologiques de nos vies.
C'est notre summum bonum.
Ce n'est pas d'augmentez le nombre de nos petits-enfants.
Voilà un effet biologique important.
Subordonner notre intérêt génétique à d'autres intérêts.
Et aucune autre espèce ne fait quelque chose qui ressemble à ça.
Bon, et que pensez de tout ça?
D'un coté, c'est un effet biologique, et un très gros.
Pas d'erreur possible.
Et quelles théories souhaite-t-on utiliser pour l'étudier?
Et bien, plusieurs. Mais qu'est ce qui peut bien les relier?
L'idée d'idée auto-répliquante;
d'idées qui se répliquent en passant de cerveau à cerveau.
Richard Dawkins, dont vous entendrez parler tout à l'heure, a inventé le terme de "mèmes",
et construit la première version vraiment claire et vivante de cette idée
dans son livre "le gène égoïste".
Et me voilà, parlant de son idée.
Et justement, maintenant, ce n'est plus la sienne. Alors oui, il l'a lancée.
Mais elle est à tout le monde maintenant.
Il n'est pas responsable de ce que je dis sur les mèmes.
J'en suis responsable.
en fait, je pense que nous ne sommes pas seulement responsables
des effets attendus de nos idées,
mais de leurs mauvaises utilisations probables.
Donc c'est important, je pense, pour Richard et moi,
que nos idées ne soient pas dévoyées ou mal utilisées.
Il est très facile de mal les utiliser. C'est pour ça qu'elles sont dangereuses.
Et c'est un vrai travail
d'essayer d'empêcher les gens effrayés par ces idées
de les caricaturer et de les utiliser d'un horrible objectif à l'autre.
On doit donc les suivre de loin,
essayer de corriger les incompréhensions
de façon à ce que seules les variantes bénignes et utiles de nos idées continuent de circuler.
Mais c'est un vrai problème.
On a pas beaucoup de temps, je vais approfondir un petit peu et passer à autre chose,
il y a beaucoup de choses à dire.
Permettez moi juste de vous faire remarquer : Les mèmes sont comme des virus.
C'est ce que disais déjà Richard en 93.
Vous pourriez pensez "Mais, comment est-ce possible?".
Un virus, c'est, vous savez, un truc! De quoi est fait un mème?
Hier, Negroponte parlait des communications virales
mais, qu'est ce qu'un virus?
Un virus est une chaine d'acides nucléiques avec du caractère.
(Rires)
Et bien, c'est un peu
ce qui lui permet de se répliquer mieux que ses compétiteurs
Et c'est ce qu'est un mème; un paquet d'information avec un caractère.
De quoi est fait un mème? De quoi est fait un octet Maman?
Pas de silicone.
Ils sont faits d'information, et peuvent être enregistrés sur n'importe quel support physique.
De quoi est fait un mot?
Parfois, quand les gens demandent "Est ce que les mèmes existent?"
Je réponds "Et bien, est ce que les mots existent? Font-ils partie de notre ontologie?"
Si oui, les mots sont des mèmes qui peuvent être prononcés.
Et dans ce cas il y a tous les autres mèmes qui ne peuvent pas être prononcés.
Il y a plusieurs espèces de mèmes.
Vous vous rappelez des "Shakers"? Taillés pour être simple?
Des meubles simple et beau?
Bon, bien sur, ils sont presqu'éteint maintenant.
et l'une des raisons est que dans le credo du Shaker
est qu'il faut rester célibataire.
Pas juste les prêtres, tout le monde.
Bon, ce n'est pas si surprenant qu'ils se soient éteints (Rires).
Mais ce n'est pas pour ça qu'ils se sont éteints.
Ils ont survécu tant que
les systèmes de sécurité sociale n'étaient pas là.
Il y avait beaucoup de veuves et d'orphelins,
des gens qui avaient besoins d'une maison adoptive.
Et comme ça, ils avaient des convertis tout prêt.
Et ils pouvaient continuer.
En principe, ça aurait pu durer pour toujours.
Avec un célibat parfait du coté des hôtes.
Les idées passaient grâce au prosélytisme
plutôt que par la lignée génétique.
Donc les idées peuvent survivre malgré le fait
qu'elles ne sont pas transmises génétiquement.
Un mème peut se développer en dépit du fait qu'il a un impact négatif sur le bien-être génétique.
Après tout, le mème du Shaker était principalement un parasite stérilisant.
Il y a d'autres parasites qui le font, qui rendent l'hôte stérile.
Ça fait partie de leur plan.
Ils n'ont pas besoin d'esprits pour avoir un plan.
Je vais porter votre attention sur une seule
des nombreuses implications de la perspective mémétique, celle que je défend.
Je n'ai pas le temps d'approfondir plus.
Dans le livre merveilleux de Jared Diamond, "De l'inégalité parmi les sociétés",
il parle du fait que ce sont les microbes, pas les armes et l'acier,
qui ont conquis le nouvel hémisphère, celui de l'ouest...
et qui a conquis le reste du monde.
Quand les explorateurs et voyageurs européens sont arrivés
ils ont apportés avec eux des germes
contre lesquels ils étaient quasiment immunisés,
pour lesquels ils avaient acquis une tolérance,
des centaines et des centaines d'années, des milliers d'années,
à vivre avec des animaux domestiqués qui étaient la source de ces pathogènes.
Et ils les ont fait disparaître, ces pathogènes ont fait disparaître les autochtones,
qui n'avaient aucune immunité contre eux.
Et on recommence.
Mais avec des idées toxiques cette fois.
Hier, beaucoup de monde, Nicholas Negroponte et d'autres,
ont parlé des choses merveilleuses
qui arrivent quand les idées circulent à travers le monde
grâce aux nouvelles technologies.
Et je suis d'accord. C'est majoritairement merveilleux. Majoritairement merveilleux.
Mais parmi toutes ces idées qui circulent inévitablement à travers le monde
grâce à nos technologies, se trouvent beaucoup d'idées toxiques.
On s'en ait rendu compte il y a quelques temps déjà.
Sayyid Qutb est l'un des pères fondateurs de l'Islam extrémiste,
un des idéologues qui a inspiré Oussama ben Laden.
De même, "il suffit de jeter un coup d'œil à ces films de presse, défilés de mode, concours de beauté,
salle de danse, bar à vin et stations de télévision". Mèmes.
Ces mèmes se répandent à travers le monde
et ils anéantissent des cultures complètes.
Ils anéantissent des langues.
Ils anéantissent des traditions et des pratiques.
Et ce n'est pas de notre faute, pas plus que quand nos germes se transmettent
à des gens qui ne sont pas immunisé.
Nous sommes immunisés contre les déchets qui traînent à la marge de notre culture.
Nous sommes une société libre, donc nous autorisons la pornographie et toutes ces choses.
Ça ne nous fait ni chaud ni froid.
Pour nous, ce n'est pas grand chose.
Mais il faudrait qu'on se rende compte que c'est énorme
pour beaucoup de gens dans le monde.
Et on devrait y faire attention,
au fur et à mesure que notre éducation et notre technologie se répandent,
ce que l'on fait c'est que, nous sommes les vecteurs de mèmes
qui sont à raison, considérés par les hôtes de nombreux autres mèmes
comme une menace directe envers leurs mèmes préférés,
les mèmes pour lesquels ils sont préparés à mourir.
Bon, et comment différencier les bons mèmes des mauvais?
Ce n'est pas le travail de la science de la mèmétique.
La mèmétique est moralement neutre, et c'est bien comme ça.
Il n'y a pas de place pour la haine et la colère.
Si un de vos amis meure du SIDA, alors vous allez haïr le HIV.
Mais pour régler le problème il faut passer par la science,
comprendre comment cela se répand et pourquoi ; de façon moralement neutre.
Prendre les faits.
Déduire les implications.
On a tout le temps pour des passions morales une fois qu'on a les faits
et qu'on sait comment agir au mieux.
Et, comme avec les microbes, le truc n'est pas d'essayer de les annihiler.
Jamais vous ne pourrez les détruire.
Ce que vous pouvez faire, par contre, c'est favoriser des mesures de santé publiques ou autre
qui encourageront l'évolution vers l'avirulence.
Et qui encourageront la circulation de mutations relativement bénignes
des variantes les plus toxiques.
Je n'ai plus de temps,
alors merci beaucoup pour votre attention.